[Music]  hey what's up guys good to be here in  texas  [Music]  i love it here because there's so many  big booty latinas  [Applause]  asian women don't have that big a booty  it's like damn have you never picked up  anything off the ground before  not even a paperclip  it's uh interesting you know it's like  we're doing squats now it's 20 21. get  with it uh but i do love the ladies  i i think it's weird that i'm dating in  my 30s now dating in my 30s is weird  because i'm like oh hey look at that  girl i can imagine hating her in five  years  you know women they're all about  pro-choice until it comes to deciding  where to eat for dinner am i  why don't you pro choose a restaurant